[MUSIC PLAYING]
CECILE LEROUX: UKG
is a leading provider
of HR talent, workforce
management, and payroll
solutions.
And our focus is
absolutely on people.
In fact, our tagline, which
is much more than a tagline,
is that our purpose is people.
So when we think about some
of the major challenges
that our organization faced
and just like our customers are
facing is that the reality
is that the rules of work
are being rewritten.
And we wanted to be part of
rewriting those rules of work
rather than just reacting
to what's happening in--
with so much uncertainty.
So again, this need to
be incredibly adaptive
led us to really wanting to
take this DevOps approach.
How do we implement life-work
technology internally as well
as for our customers?
One of the things
that we recognized
is that we had to be
hyper, hyper aware
of whether or not individuals
were nearing burnout,
for example.
What is it that we
could do to understand
the makeup and the
cohesion of teams
to ensure that we had
consistent output and throughput
without overtaxing individuals?
Whenever you see a
challenge-- or whenever
we, certainly, at
UKG sees a challenge,
we think about it in terms of
what is the person approach?
How is that impacting
people individually and as
a whole, or teams?
And so we see opportunities
to actually bring new products
to the market based on
what our experiences are.
We took the approach
of really adopting
some Cloud-native
attributes and capability
that would actually
support kind of decoupling
our releases from the
development lifecycle
so that we could
accelerate and bring
more value to our customers.
We have a significant
amount of cloud storage.
But the most important
benefit that we
found with our
deployment, in particular,
of using some of the
Cloud-native capabilities
that GCP offered us to
change our delivery,
reduce downtime significantly,
and also add resilience
to our overall
delivery-- so being
able to do continuous
integration
and continuous delivery,
taking advantage
of some of the metrics that
came, as well as deploying.
In one of our
platforms, we actually
have deployed the entire
suite of Google Analytics
and embedded those
directly in so
that we can see where
usage is happening.
The Google team was
incredible in understanding
how important those three
principles were to our teams.
So we were able to get
at-- in particular,
I want to call out the AI and
the machine learning team,
because we got so much from our
collaboration with that team,
as well as across the board,
the leadership, the partner
team, the partner
organization, in really shaping
how we could take advantage
of some of those capabilities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]